I believe in education I believe in
knowing more tomorrow than I knew today
you get education of course a lot of
different ways and a good way to get in
a good education as we call it is to get
a good college degree we've lost our
minds though on this college stuff and
people go out and spend 150,000 bucks
and student loan debt to get a PhD in
German polka history or some such crap
right and so people get these degrees
that are useless they study these
mundane obtuse things that don't have
anything to do with anything and it's
giving a college education a bad name so
I don't have anything against the
college education I did get a funny
funny funny thing in from Dan Miller a
few minutes ago dan Miller of 48 days to
the work you love he said David my
continued research on into how education
is changing it became clear this is not
exactly a new idea in 1744 when George
Washington was just a twelve-year-old
boy the collected Chiefs of the Indian
nations met to discuss a letter from the
College of William and Mary suggesting
they'd send 12 of their young men to
college that they might be taught to
read and write
the Chiefs sent the fault the Indian
chiefs sent the following reply we know
that you highly esteem the kind of
learning taught in colleges and that the
maintenance of our young men while with
you would be very expensive to you we
are convinced therefore that you meant
to do us good by your proposal and we
thank you heartily but you who are wise
must know that different nations have
different conceptions of things and you
will therefore not take it amiss if our
ideas of this kind of Education happen
to not be the same with yours we have
some experience of it several of our
young men were formally brought up at
the college's of the northern provinces
they were instructed in all your
sciences but when they came back to us
they were bad runners ignorant of every
means of living in the woods
unable to bear either cold or hunger
knew neither how to build a cabin take
dear or kill an enemy spoke our
languages imperfectly and therefore
neither and therefore neither fit for
hunters warriors nor counselors they
were totally good-for-nothing we are
however not the less obliged to your
kind offer though we decline accepting
it and to show our grateful sense of it
the gentleman of Virginia well if the
gentleman of Virginia will send us a
dozen of their sons we will take care of
their education instruct them in all
that we know and make men of them oh
that's just wonderful it's absolutely
fabulous
send your college boys over here and we
will make men of them the first time the
frat boys were insulted right there I
love it 17:44 you believe that date in
the language you have to love the
language absolutely amazing someone was
obviously trained in the English
language and well fabulous stuff you
guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others